هذا العاجل الذي نشاهده على شاشتنا ويعلن
فيه الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ضابط من لواء
جفعاتي خلال معاركه في غزه معنا من غلاف
غزه مراسلنا الياس كرام الياس هل توافرت
معلومات عن الظروف التي قتل فيها هذا
الضابط من لواء
جفعاتي الجيش الاسرائيلي عاده لا يفصل في
الاسباب التي ادت الى مقتل الجنود
الاسرائيليين لكنه يشير الى انها تمت في
معارك في منطقه جنوب قطاع غزه هذه هذه
المره وهذا الضابط هو الثاني هذا اليوم
الذي يعلن عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بياناته الرسميه حتى هذه الساعه ومن
الواضح بان العمليات العسكريه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه ايه تتخذ زخما اكبر وشراسه اكبر
ودراوه اكبر وهذا ما يؤكده الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا في بياناته حيث كان اعلن
بالامس انه اضطر الى الدفع بلواء كامل
جديد وزج به في معارك المنطقه الجنوبيه
لقطاع غزه وهذا مؤشر على ان الجنود على
الارض بحاجه الى اسناد هم في مازق كما
يبدو بحاجه الى اسناد بري والى مزيد من
القوات للعمل والتوغل وربما السيطره
الناريه على منطقه خانيونس والمناطق
الشرقيه من هذه المدينه التي كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن بانه توغل بها وسيطر
عليها لكن واضح بان السيطره ليست تامه ذلك
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي بحاجه الى الدفع
بلواء كامل الى تلك المنطقه لتعزيز وجوده
العسكري وتعزيز قواته واسناد القوات التي
دخلت الى تلك المناطق في الاسابيع الماضيه
هذا بالاضافه الى كتائبه اخرى من لواء
الهندسه التي دفع بها الى تلك المنطقه
تحديدا وهي ستكون مسؤوله بحسب بيان ال
الجيش الاسرائيلي عن مزيد من الكشف عن
الانفاق الهجوميه وحده جفعاتي التي
قتل فيها هذا الضابط الاسرائيلي هي واحده
من وحدات النخبه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
وتحديدا في سلاح ال البر وكان لافتا في
الايام الماضيه الارقام والمعطيات التي
صدرت بخصوص مقتل الجنود والضباط من وحدات
النقبه في الجيش الاسرائيلي تحديدا في
وحده دوف ديفان عسكريه هذه الوحده التي
شكلت في عام 86 على يد رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق يهود براك والذي كان ايضا رئيسا
لهيئه الاركان العامه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
هذه الوحده قتل فيها ضابط واحد منذ
تاسيسها في عام
86 كان هذا في مخيم الامعري في رام الله
في عام 2018 منذ بدايه هذه الحرب في
السابع من اكتوبر قتل لهذه الوحده حده ع
من الجنود الاسرائيليين والضباط وهذا يعطي
فكره عن حجم المعارك ودراوه المعارك
وشراستها في كل المناطق في داخل قطاع غزه
بمعنى من عام 86 وحتى هذا العام جندي واحد
قتيل لهذه الوحده وهي من وحدات النخبه
العسكريه اي المستعربين ومنذ بدايه هذا ال
هذه الحرب هنالك عشره قتلى لهذه الوحده
كذلك هو الحال مع وحده شلدا وحده شلدا
التي تشكلت في عام 67 هذه وحده من وحدات
النخبه الاربعه في الجيش الاسرائيلي وهي
تتبع لسلاح الجو مهمتها تقصي الحقائق وجمع
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه من ارض العدو بين
هلالين او من ارض الخصم وهذه الوحده لم
يقتل احد من جنودها منذ تاسيسها اي
البيانات تشير الى ان هنالك سته الى سبعه
جنود وضباط لهذه الوحده قتلوا منذ بدايه
هذه الحرب اسرائيل دفعت بوحدات النخبه في
العمل العسكري وتحديدا منذ بدايه العمليه
البريه لكن واضح بان هذه الوحدات النخبوي
تتعرض ايضا
لعمليات عمليات عسكريه ولمواجهه شرسه في
من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه في داخل قطاع
غزه ونحن ما زلنا نحن انتقلنا مره اخرى
الى المناطق الشماليه الان نحن امام
الشجاعيه وجباليا وهذه مناطق يفترض ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال بانه سيطر عليها
ناريا وعملات في الايام الماضيه فقط
بالامس اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه سيطر
عملات على جباليا لكن نحن ما زلنا نرى بان
القصف عنيف والان من فوقنا تحوم طائرات اف
16 المقاتله ويبدو انها ستغير مره اخرى
على جباليا او ربما على الشجاعيه التي
تعرضت هذا الصباح الى قصف مدفعي عنيف والى
غارات جويه تكاد تكون غير مسبوقه اي دمرت
كثيرا من المنازل والبنى التحتيه في
المناطق الشرقيه لحي الشجاعيه تقريبا
القريبه من السياج الامني ونحن شاهدنا
وربما ما زلنا نشاهد عبر الصوره الان هذا
الدمار الكبير الذي الحقته الغارات الجويه
والقصف المدفعي في الايام الاخيره تلك
المناطق الشاسعه التي دمرها وسواها هذا
القصف بالارض على اعتبار انه ويبدو ان
اسرائيل تريد ان تفرغ هذه المنطقه من اي
مبان سكنيه من اجل السيطره العسكريه عليها
وتحويلها الى عمق استراتيجي او عمق امني
لحمايه البلدات الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه
بعد انتهاء الحرب في منظور اقامت ما يسمى
الحزام الامني في تلك المناطق